all right I am going to hop in to
the Eastern bullet Arena
a mini light join
let's do it
so if you'd like to hop in
you could track it down easily there you
go
all right let's do it
55 minutes
Benjamin benoni hello in the twitch chat
I'm not a mouse
anonymous 81.
space
no Knight G4
let's cut out anything here
the B file
hmm
okay
I get a passer I got a passer
all right oh hang on Queen there now
Queen there isn't anything
two connected passers
Bishop there
this and then that
it's one check
it's not a big deal though
I just want to control the promotion
Square
or there
even if it's guarded
on two
almost
no stalemates
I got the first one
get 20 some games in
all right someone's pointing out the
record for tomorrow gray of
holy cow
40
holds the record
from 2016
he did 48 blindfold games
ridiculous
can you guys play blindfold
oh
trying to
deliver a mate
on f8 no mate
okay
what's going on here
um
I'm doing way too much thinking
way too much
gotta go much faster
trying to play correct chess
oh why'd I do that I'm just giving away
a pawn
silly
and a file
why are you doing that
stop giving away material
and there's a beautiful Square there
holy cow and I just walked into a pin oh
awful
another pin I'm there
oh boy
oh
man stop playing correct chess you're
losing all your seconds
Mickey you can't remember when you did
what you did 10 minutes ago
I know that is such a remarkable feat
huh
not enough people know about that
40 I knew he was the blindfold King
blindfold King I knew he
did a ton of games I just didn't know it
was that high 48.
ridiculous
all right as I just blender
it's not blender
blender it again
all right can we whip up a an attack
control the Knight jumps
drop upon scare Night Away
is the night dead Phoenix
why am I trading off the fan cutout
night
control the Knight maintain B4
your only forward move is the capture
I still need a flight Square
uh that's not a great flight Square
hang on
trying to give checks and stuff
all right there resign
okey dokey
Dr dremate thank you for the prime resub
two months yeah thanks for all the
entertainment Jerry
all right
French turned King's Indian attack
Maybe
not
be careful about F2
no King's Indian attack it's ready to
blunder my Bishop
control the Knight
resolve pins
think things are under control
put a little pressure there see what
happens
maybe I should consider that one
hmm okay
dark Bishops are gone
assuming they're gone
they're gone
space
Rook here could be a move
could be a move and it is a move Bishop
here
it's a lot of stuff on those light
squares
hmm
chicken move
Forks
two miners
another chicken move
making a lot of chicken moves
what are chicken moves
it's got to be at least one person
asking what are chickens it's making
stuff up
what are chicken moves
maybe that's what my game is missing
chicken moves
scaredy cat moves is another term
phrase
poison
guy
let's be a developer
maybe I should hit him with D5 a little
sooner there
clean or yeah let's go with the queen
maybe something exciting happens on the
long light diagonal I'm opposite the
queen
hmm
no
can't explain it oh okay this bishop is
having a tough day now
trade oh they're giving me that
my dark Square Bishop wants to do
something amazing
can we do something amazing
are there any tricks there might be a
trick soon careful careful careful
pins
okay
oh
got the Queenie
crashing through now
taking stuff
all right
we're in there
uh nifa thank you or excuse me Phil
thy
filthy thank you for the prime sub
nifa thank you for the Prime resub 11
months
and code block
thank you for the tier one resub 70th
okay I still had seconds left five
seconds
how to make a move
thank you for your support man
all of you
subscribing
watching
all of it
Dive In
let's dive in Forks
it's a big weakness now
how aggressive do I want to be on the
king's side we're going to find out
what is my king up to no good
maybe I should have captured the Knight
first
why'd I do that
all right we'll go here we're gonna get
the queen trade
I'm gonna drive that Knight away
I don't know actually maybe
yeah let's get rid of them
oh I had mate you dummy
oh come on basic mates learn them we got
Forks
let's go for the fork
now I'm gonna get mated no
there we go it's under control
fancy
now stalemates
okay they resigned
all right
yassar is proud
I grabbed the pawn
he is a pond grabber
all right that's usually uh
not the best decision to release that
tension because now there's a big hole
here that
I believe with
some precise maneuvering
um
I should be able to take advantage of it
I
ideally I'm looking for this exact
exchange dark Square Bishops
so I have some stuff going for me now
I don't know why I chased that
Knight to a good Square Knight A4 I'm
expecting
oh now now this could be
a problem
all right let's give this guy up and
focus on the dark squares oh
slowly improved now
big dark Square grip
um maybe I was too fast with that one
don't move the f-bone
I want to guard my base points first
I blundered now I have Queen C7
queen queen C3 Queen C7
give the check
oh
and where's the mate
all right
all right
I'll try
we will try it's gonna say French
I guess that's what we have
hmm
okay I'm going to track down my dark
Square bishop or not
Bishop C6 in reply to
Bishop B5 no big deal there
to take Extra Care over the light
squares this is probably an error
I guess the knight's gonna arrive on C4
definitely cannot take it
wow
no Knight takes Rook
now he takes upon I could play there
it may soon be the case that that Knight
is out of play I don't know
I can't really allow you to do that
I need my light Square Bishop
I guess I'm
foreign
I just realized I have a really big time
Edge
okay I was
moving quick
under 40.
hello Fred Nicole
French
I allowed that move
uh let's hang on for a little bit
capturing is perfectly fine but I just
feel like the Queen's gonna maybe
struggle to find a square
so
let's maybe not trade too soon
I don't like being in this pin
it's resolved
uh Bishop here why am I not
am I not doing that
careful careful
let's try this
that what's wrong with the forward move
Bishop C4 was there
that'd be annoying
my Bishops are going to be annoying
oh
they were covering a lot of ground
control
okay
we're getting there
still have a streak
the silver bravery doing good
how are you doing
it's Friday evening
yeah I really need to play a different
system here I I
it's too often the case I get a really
bad position
with this setup
I'm going to have this available
and apply to Queen G3
it's still go here
I don't mind having to recapture on the
square of my queen
not too bad
stop any tricks make sure my queen is
defended
maybe have that one in there
not quite
mm-hmm
I'm dropping this pun dummy
and get the coins off at least
I think the Queens are coming off or not
wow what a move nice one
I think I have all the important jumps
covered
whoa
nice I'm getting mated
or no I'm not I'm my queen could block
oh man
got nine lives
I almost believed that that was gonna be
a winner
Duck and Cover
but
crawl up into a ball
and hope that the time runs out that's
what that move was all about right there
please don't mate me let me defend this
directly
okay it's almost a lockdown it's a lock
tone
tall Pond syndrome
and from here there is a systematic
approach
trade bad for good and go from there
I don't care about castling
inch by inch we're going to get there
there's the break
new Target I could have grabbed that
pawn
there's nothing wrong with that
new file
there's the material
get to the file
okay they resigned
if you could as white if you're able to
provoke G5
um in that F5 Square becomes a hole for
black
it's a usually leads to some grinding
type positions
I think it's just a strategically
desirable structure and
there's ways to slowly improve
for white not so much for black
should be able to get in there one way
or the other
this I think that's a really strong
attacking piece so
um
let's take here
I don't like to okay let's go here
they're not threatening that just yet
I have this Knight oh I could take here
first and then go here
I'm on The Rook
I don't like what I'm doing here this is
awful
oh that was a good pre-move
that guy always flies man
oh
okay we're in the first spot right now
still 29 to go
go go go
and if they're playing conservative and
so am I
really fumbling
with my moves
just gonna be Trading
okay stop any G4 idea I still have a
pawn break in the position
this is just barely working I did not
work these details out
in full
okay they resigned
I should have spent a few more seconds
making sure I think that was right
though
correct result probably more
variations to run the numbers on
okay
incoming
don't want to see that
why'd I do this
Bishop takes Pawn
your dummy
so watch out for that skewer
I could take a check
I want to push
oh I didn't see that move
oh
oh
close close have I ever considered
playing go
not really no
okay
and the tank
why'd I do that
really asking for trouble
what am I doing
like garbage
this last few moves
check
a bishop on G6 has to be pretty annoying
oh
well stalemates man
they always shave off a second or two
you gotta weigh the
you gotta weigh the the position is it
stalemate or not
we've been here before let's
before I couldn't play this because my
Bishop was on this
D6 Square
all right okay try it again
now this guy's more accessible that
backward B Pawn
okay
take care
take here
can't contest this file so easily
oh G5
I'll go for this
do get a pawn
I want this
let's hang on to that for a minute
okay
you're cruising
20 20 minutes remaining 5 24 in there
Santana
all right let's go with this dubious oh
okay they didn't
it's just uh it's turned into a French
that early capture I like having that
because my Knight has C3
Queen check I could come back
I'm gonna say they could have that
I don't want it
night jump soon
Knight A4 I think was necessary
hmm
I want to get this in soon
we're there
oh that's an
a sneaky move
oh
locking that pawn now
you're being sneaky that was the one
move I was watching out for
they might try that to
track down the pawn
got that square covered
got a lot of temp Tempe against the
queen
she's vacuuming up a lot of pieces
I almost blundered my queen
oh
I could have also played G6 what am I
doing let's play G6 now
no stalemates to worry about
push push push
almost mate
all right
64.68 just updated 16 to go
the expert let's try E4
Sicilian
okay close Sicilian Maybe
oh I should have moved my queen first oh
they didn't
I thought they were going to push
I want this tempo
Queen F3 blocking the checks
it's really convenient
should be getting to the file soon my
knight on C4 cannot be dislodged
um
I guess
Target this guy
hmm
I didn't see that that was a thing
no checks
go with this outside passer let's fix
this Pawn I want to hunt
the other Rook Pawn
and get him back in the ball game
everything's frozen now
no stalemates to worry about
kinkagawa h6h5
okay CL Smith thank you for the raid
just the tail end here playing some
bullet
CL Smith if I'm not mistaken is a
scrabbled wizard
do I have that right
h o Mouse slipper no take backs
little take backs allowed in the rain
Arena format
5 56 in there
you wish you were the Scrabble wizard
speedy
okay
might get a lock down in this position
or not
castling was wrong
shouldn't have castled
oh I didn't want to go there
trouble
okay that didn't hurt me
what am I doing
ah faster
I lost control here
dropped upon
do you have a time Edge though
okay
11 to go
I shouldn't have castled there that uh
H Pawn they could have provoked G3 and I
really don't want to have to play G3
no B5
let's go here
let's get it in
nothing tricky I don't think so
I can give a check and defend my Rook
um
get on your mind that night post
think we're there
with check
okay 10 remaining
um oh we played in what was it a Simo
that was a slime no some some game from
a stream stream game
might have been a simul
um
I think I just want to grab the bishop
and now this Knight is amazing on C5
it's an iron grip over the
over the entire Queen side
I feel like I don't even want a castle
let's take here
prepare to get an open file
open h
I want to secure this point
I have to worry about this now
Queen Exchange
it was probably stupid idea what I did
here
I think you make some progress over here
could have captured that
both my rigs are active I want to keep
it like that
okay
a dark Square controlled all started
with
being able to clamp down a B3 there
that one hole and I was able to Pivot
about on those Queen side squares and
establish a strong minor in the end
I should have captured the Knight is
poorly placed on A6
takes a little a little bit to
get activated
this trick is Tethered to this
Pawn
it's an inconvenience
flight Square
okay let's get a rook off
this point is the one I want to cover
sort of like in the
Whatchamacallit in the street in the uh
Simo
Knight's actually trapped
it's a good placement for The Rook like
this controls a lot of the night squares
five inchange
576 in there
two more
for sure maybe a third
okay
each file or not
a file
no time to stop the B5 break
back off here there's no Rook defense
the check
okay
one more for the tournament
the uh
orangutan
I really don't want a castle
all right let's make sure that guy's
gone
hmm that was an easy one to miss
all right
get one more will it count is the
question
how long have I been playing chess since
I was
eight
42.
to answer your next question
not sure why it took me so long to make
that move
I don't know if I want a castle
why is my queen on C2
Castle now
I'd like to have all majors come off
could also maneuver blockade
blockading 101
still go with the light Square blockade
should be a smooth conversion
maybe I should have captured
that's the clock
it's not going to finish
and see if my knight could oh okay I
should be able to track this down now
I'm covering that D2 Square
and I missed that
I'm going to force the king back before
I take here
all right they're down on time that's
going to do it 592 in there
top
370-69 there's your page one let's look
at the first 50.
two three
uh best in Blitz is in there
don't know who that is
top 50.
all right
good games all
fun as usual
Eastern bullet Arena